this month the world is remembering the
life of Nelson Mandela under his
leadership the end of apartheid in 1994
led to dramatic social and political
change in South Africa hello to find out
what these changes have meant for
science I met two young South African
researchers who were schoolchildren when
apartheid ended Heinrich badenhorst grew
up in Pretoria and now works on
renewable energies and Jackson Mara
kilala comes from a small village and
studies the link between HIV and
tuberculosis I'm interested in how
science has changed in south africa over
the last few decades when your country
has seen such change do you remember
either of you the end of apartheid we
vividly remember I remember I was a
little kid sitting in the lounge seeing
Mandela being released I think every
South African was glued to the TV that
day true i remember very well that i can
picture my late brother who was
listening to radio i didn't know much
but I'd always heard of the name Mandela
and release Mandela campaigns and how
did the end of apartheid change for you
and the educational opportunities that
were there for you the first time I
heard news that I was allowed to go to
his mixed school in our locality local
town was when I was already at high
school and it was an opportunity but
still it was for those who could afford
it was noted default that the fact that
it's open to everyone that everyone
could afford so there were still
processes involved on how the inclusion
itself would actually include everyone
in that simple manner hi how about you
did the end of apartheid make a
difference to the opportunities that
were available for you we obviously come
from vastly different backgrounds and I
grew up in the city and I went to the
city schools and I remember when all
this change took place I kind of I was
left with a feeling of I don't really
understand what the big deal is
my perspective there was never any
animosity the big sort of sectioning of
society happened before my time so we
were already being raised in the the
sort of transition period where there
were the segregation wasn't as clear cut
I think they were people were forced to
start thinking about the implications of
what they had done and so yeah from my
perspective very little changed truly
Jackson and what was the change of a
bigger deal for you in your community it
was such a shock culturally to some
extremes that I really had to try and
adapt to this exciting change that I
have but with time I found myself really
being part of it but whenever I do visit
back home I realize how much how much of
a change is still needed in that
particular village and how much in terms
of opportunity we still have to do on
the ground to try and give each and
every person such an opportunity you
know if somebody comes to Johannesburg
or Cape Town Pretoria so you wouldn't
see a difference between any other first
nations city I think we have the same
adverts on TV we buy the same products
its global community but the second you
go out of the cities that's when you
realize what we're the problems or we're
the reasons or that we're still a
developing nation and we need to develop
more now then do you think the issue is
not so much race but of this widening
gap between the rich and the poor and is
that now where the tension is in the
country yeah I definitely think that's
true i mean if you look at what happened
at Marikana if you look at the the
service delivery strikes the teacher
strikes all of this is not rice rice
based anymore the economy needs to be
able to support the needs of the people
and I think yeah that's where the big
problems are coming from now we we were
talking about education but often what
happens is the most educated people then
leave
and go to America go to Europe to the
best universities there the so called
brain drain are you worried about that
in South Africa well what did worry me
is if I i think i'm happy with prospects
of having south africans going to to
what is perceived to be the better way
to study and learn new technologies and
bring them home that's really great but
if they decide to stay there it's a loss
to the country to lose one person who
has a monstrous oh he has a degree or
PhD and I think it's what's worrying but
also we have other situations where
South Africans can just be involved in a
system where there's a research set up
and they just worked as technicians and
they just help to get samples and so on
and samples are sent abroad and people
abroad do great research and really they
credit in terms of research you know
prosperity go to the platoon research
outside but I also think it's a new form
of colonization of our own science so to
some extent i also hope and dream for a
situation where we can have good
capacity to train our own people living
at home that gone are the days we would
look at you care you as wherever is the
only solution where people should be
sent that I think if skills good skills
good resources enough to take care of
our own people living in terms of
Education do you feel a responsibility
to apply your knowledge in South Africa
to South African problems absolutely I
think it's a huge opportunity from my
perspective in renewable energy I think
we have some of the highest solar fluxes
on the planet so it's really we're in
the ideal environment to develop
solutions that fit this and it will be
exportable right if we can manage to do
it correctly we can attract top
scientists that's one positive very
positive thing for the recently awarded
meerkat array so the Square Kilometre
Array that's you know one of the biggest
radio telescopes in the world and we
really need I think projects like that
that are focused on perhaps not the
astronomy and it's a problem at its
fundamental work so
for example or renewable energy where we
can focus on our resources develop
something that we can then not only
export to the world but attract some
experts back and you know really create
a center of excellence in Africa for you
know I think South Africa is really in a
big sense a leader in Africa so if we
can show that it's possible and we can
show that you know we can be successful
at this these opportunities all over to
do the same thing our politicians in
South Africa supportive of science or do
you find there more of a hindrance than
a help yeah I think politicians will be
politicians as a scientist my lecturer
at university used to say that I can
tell the egg is rotten but I can't tell
you what to do about it so yeah I I find
it quite frustrating to see the amount
of money that gets wasted and that gets
spent on things that are really supposed
to make a difference like for example
housing and how it gets perhaps you know
funneled and redirected and you end up
with a really poor quality product and
that breaks down after a while it's just
it's extremely frustrating to know that
there is this available and then it's
somehow gets I don't know lost in the
big system what do you think your role
is and your generation role is in the
future of South Africa well our
generation is the first one that's
facing a global issue and so it's on
everybody in south africa i think it's
the same thing it's no longer this this
community that community its everybody
needs to come together to make the
difference so i guess the only thing as
a scientist I can really do is try as
much as I can to help students coming
into the university to encourage them to
integrate and work together and sort of
get this common vision and common goal
of you know where we want to be in which
way we should be going
how we should be getting me Jackson as a
researcher working on TB and HIV in the
lab how how are you going to translate
that into you know changes in health
care on the ground I think first it's
it's really not upon my shoulders alone
I really hope for a better cooperation
from government providing platforms for
me to be able to share my findings and
advice on how those could find a role in
promoting a better primary healthcare
system so that actually would involve an
integrative manner in which everyone on
the ground is involved so so that's the
best I hope for really a good support
from from government good support from
people who were involved from all
stakeholders really none government how
policymakers you know find funders and
so on right now everybody is reflecting
on the life of Nelson Mandela and how
South Africa has changed in the last few
decades how do you feel as you look back
at that recent history and do you feel
optimistic about the future so I think
the cleverest thing that I have to say
about Nelson Mandela perhaps if Desmond
Tutu headed Truth and Reconciliation
Commission that had to do with first
healing healing the old wounds you know
and making the point that we started a
fresh slate where everyone feels like
I'm very much part of this country and I
have to work for this when he managed to
defuse the situation which was
potentially disastrous I mean it could
have gone horribly wrong think he was an
icon as I say and his legacy will live
long provided that following leaders
would actually follow in his footsteps
in terms of treating each and every
member of the society as and high
quality no I think South Africa is now
at a turning point where it's no longer
the politicians that need to make the
difference it's the people so I think
it's really positive that when I look at
previous election or the most recent
elections you see the younger generation
start to think for themselves kind of so
start to think
not along historical lines but start to
think along the future and what they
want and how they want the country to be
run so I think it's extremely good that
we don't end up having you know a
majority that can just do whatever they
want and there's no consequences so in
this sense I'm very positive in the
sense that it looks as though there's a
shift in power and I think that's always
good to have a balance to make sure that
the people in power aren't abusing it